[Music]
you just want me to fail
everybody here wants me to fail ever
keep clapping
you're nothing without me
happy tuesday everyone but is it really
happy
not when it's day two of
joe barton son of a [ __ ] gator get an
insurrection
yes it was just 24 hours ago the world
was rocked by an insidious foul-mouthed
display of incoherent rage
it was the slanderer in chief lashing
out at our very own
peter ducey
who was simply gathering information for
a school book report
do you think in places of political
liability ahead of the midterms
that's a great asset
more
inflation what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
in case you missed it let's do it again
slow-mo
the original sob salty old biden strikes
again
of course the target of his wrath was
the one reporter who asked questions joe
can't answer on autopilot fox news is
peter ducey or as we like to say our
very own
like we raised him in a plastic bubble
we took a clipping from steve ducey then
let miracle grow do the rest
ducey known for his hair and his lengthy
rap sheet was noticeably shaken up
somebody came up to me in the briefing
room a few minutes later and said did
you hear what the president said
and i said no what they said he called
you a stupid s-o-b and i said
did he say s-o-b and the person said no
well maybe he's not that shaken up
ducey who just turned 16 last week
is home recuperating spending most of
his time in his bedroom playing video
games smoking blunts and texting kill
mead about the hot new girl in homeroom
now since this event a so-called
president has called mr ducey to clear
the air which when talking about joe
usually involves opening a window and
the use of at least 75 glade plug-ins
apparently it was a perfect phone call
although odds are good joe was still
talking 10 minutes after peter hung up
but what a pair a reporter who's never
shaved and a president you wouldn't let
near anything sharp
when i say why bother this is the best
thing president biden has ever done
since
in fact it's the best thing joe biden
has ever done it's definitely the most
honest thing to come out of his come out
of him since he cropped dusted camilla
bowles with the uh air biscuit heard
around the world
it's better than beating corn pop and
break dancing up the stairs to air force
one combined because when biden called
ducey and sob what did he do
he reminded you of the good old days
when the only problems we had were
verbal
yeah let's take a walk down memory lane
or insult avenue if you will to the
glorious days of old with the only
things hurled through the air were words
and not russian missiles pointed at kiev
you're not a very good reporter doing
that crooked hillary clinton here i am
i'm lying ted cruz to the fake
pocahontas i wonder about
sleepy joe biden crazy bernie don't
worry about it a little marco little
pencil neck adam schiff uh trying to
build up your energy but it's not
working one at a time with jeb's
attitude we will never be great again
that i can tell you i love bankers
actually i was only kidding you can get
the baby out of here this
really stupid guy
get that son of a [ __ ] off the field
right now out he's fired
he's fired honestly i think you should
let me run the country you run cnn all
right and if you did it well your
ratings let me ask you
ah
those were the days when the only stress
we felt were from trump's relentless
full-throated insults it was like we had
don rickles as president his rallies
weren't so much rallies as they were
roasts the only thing missing was dean
martin and foster brooks and it reminded
you that it was not just a problem it
was really the only problem well besides
that rash i got in tulum
but there was no inflation no high crime
unless you count the coddled left-wing
mascots antifa and blm no foreign policy
disasters no education implosion no
attacks on parents no dividing america
into us versus them based on
vaccinations race or pronouns
all we had were mean tweets and some
hilarious insults
so what would you rather be doing paying
seven bucks a gallon for gas or
listening to trump call bette midler a
washed up psycho would you rather have
bear supermarket shelves or have your
president say of kneeling nfl players
get those sops off the field
you were free to get mad or laugh it off
well unless you were rosie o'donnell
you see i want more of that and less of
the other real problems
i mean what if joe just got more
trumpian and less
you know well bideny i wonder what joe
has to
say what did i say anyway would i say
you stupid son of a [ __ ] that's an
expression
it's an expression i say it all the time
i don't mean anything by it i set it to
my
cream of wheat this morning
because she burned my tongue i see a
stupid son of a
then i apologized i leaned over the bowl
and
i like to let the steam come up and i
smell it it's very nice but i said
oh my sweet farina i'm sorry i didn't
mean to say such a thing that's what i
call her on a good day my sweet farina
on a bad day
i call her a punk ass
pony soldier
it illustrates what so many people in
the media in entertainment got so wrong
about trump their derangement made them
think that his words were his d's so
they tossed out a guy who did pretty
good stuff but with a cab driver's mouth
replacing him with a supposedly genial
but declining mindless mess
turns out the new guy is about as genial
as a scorpion with jock rot
what i wouldn't give for the cab driver
instead we got grandpa simpson driving
us off a cliff meanwhile the same idiots
who castigated trump for calling
journalist names are now heaping praise
or at least excusing joe for the very
same thing it shows joe's tough he's got
backbone even though it's crumbling from
osteoporosis putin's so scared he might
even put a shirt on
so the pres press either has the memory
of a goldfish or just biased a-holes my
apologies to literal a-holes so in one
brief moment joe reminded us what we had
and what we lost and now what we are
stuck with
but also the president sets the tone and
sadly it's contagious
hey queen i just want to let you know
that on instagram all your photos of
percy are so cute thank you yeah give
that little stupid sound of a bit to
scratch for me okay
stupid son of a [ __ ]
what are you doing guys hey jesse
congratulations on the new show the
ratings thank you
are you surprised they gave it to me
that's a stupid question of course i'm
surprised you're a brain dead son of a
[ __ ]
it's not personal pal
hey judge
you know what
let's not let's not
good choice
you know i mentioned before
that the great comedian jim gaffigan
said he'd vote for joe biden's corpse
over donald trump which is funny because
he already did the only thing left is
the cremation in november
and it served as just one selfish
example of those who crusaded trump out
of office they wanted their emotional
damage reduced even if it meant electing
someone who would usher in real damage
be it domestic or international sure
they didn't have to endure the tweets or
the barbs and that helped them get to
sleep but in this trade-off our actual
physical lives are remarkably worse
whether it's rampant criminality kids
forced to wear unnecessary masks or a
possible hot war now with russia and so
they sacrificed everything to get rid of
the orange man who made them feel bad
even though his greatest real estate
deal was living rent-free in their
heads welcome tonight's guest he's made
more liberals cry than the finale of the
west wing former white house press
secretary and fox's good tributary
fleischer
he's like peter pan he doesn't age and
will never marry a woman host of the guy
benson show and fox news contributor guy
benson
she's proof that if you can't say
something nice you can get a job on tv
fox news contributor cat tim
and when he wears a green shirt in
boston they think he's fenway park by
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion taurus
guy you're a filthy filthy little little
man aren't you just filthy greg i i need
to give you a bath
you stupid son of a [ __ ]
uh three things to say on this sure in
my defense number one it was a hot mic
yes okay i forgot that i was mic'd up i
forgot there was a camera every time
with all four of them yes uh that's
number one number two
yes i may have cursed a bit
last time i was on the show in december
i believe we did a whole segment on
cursing i declined to curse but i
promised that i would next time and you
did i have paid that off in spades if i
cursed any more on tv i'd be dana
perrino
and finally
i feel like we have had our differences
through the years right
but i hope you're okay with how that
sketch went because i feel like that
might be the closest i'll ever get to
being on the five
after how that all went down so sorry
everyone love you dana love you judge
especially yeah
isn't it isn't it a contrast between how
we handle things and how cnn does like
if somebody when some when trump would
go after their people they would be like
oh my god it's the end of the world and
all we do is make fun of ducey well i
saw a guy on twitter said that if that
had been acosta and trump exactly what
happened akasa would have shown up on
cnn within a minute in a neck brace
i've been i've been harmed uh and ducey
played it perfectly blowing it off yeah
he was very funny he said that it hadn't
been fact checked yet that was very
clever good all right uh did any uh
anything like this ever happen with your
boss president bush i'm trying to
remember hot mike moments i don't know
i'm not sure yes it did oh yeah
but first of all acosta would have shown
up with the neck brace but he'd been
represented by michael avenatti
nice good um it did in the 2000 campaign
when bush ran for president he was at a
mic and he referred to a reporter from
the new york times named adam kleimer as
a major league
began with an a yes two little curly
letters and then rhymed with troll
you're right right who watched dick
cheney when he heard that said big time
yes
and that became a thing yes but the
difference was and you showed it with
the trump tape
for bush it fit the personality bush was
always a guy who could throw elbows
under the board snap a towel at you
people knew that was kind of bush in
character
but joe biden is just weird yeah it's
cranky biden's saying that's because of
what you pointed out he's supposed to be
this kind of older congenial man and
then he says something like that
it worked for trump it worked for bush
even though it was inadvertent for bush
it's definitely advertent or whatever
the opposite of yeah that's a good point
what's the opposite of inadvertent
advertising
it worked for trump yeah being
advertised yes it did i love that word
advertent
that's a great one i'm gonna start
throwing that around at my uh
meetings you know uh tyrus
the only time i got caught on a hot mic
was when i hosted the chippendales
welcome back
he creaked me out last night and then he
just keeps raising the bar
i got angry old women
sending me mean mess you wish
you had it so good so thank you greg
you know i i'm
kind of
super impressed with our very own lucy
because he clearly doesn't care about
money yeah he actually cares about being
a journalist because
yes acosta would have had the next thing
but you're forgetting the six books that
were going to come out about that
experience right
literally he got a own tv show based on
president trump hurt my feelings and his
book was literally just
every word he said and then you would
see him that he wouldn't do interviews
anymore he's like i'm standing outside
the rally and these four people called
me names yeah and he was the story and i
i commend ducey for not becoming the
story when everyone's kind of like hey
how did that feel he's like i didn't
hear it you know i just moved through it
and oh he called me and he said sorry no
you know nothing personal and he laughed
it off which is being and maybe cnn can
take a lesson here but i doubt it he's
being a journalist so all the the things
that could happen for that i applaud our
very own
uh ducey for
being staying the journalist yeah and
that and i i commended for that you know
uh i'll go to our very own cat temp um i
don't belong to anyone
you're the are the homeless yeah the
homeless cat tim um what uh what did you
make of this whole thing it's so silly
but it's great it's you know what i like
about this topic it's fun
it is fun and you know what else was fun
what was reading all the columns today
or at least the titles of them like you
know joe biden shouldn't have said that
but here's actually why it's not a big
deal it's like okay who are you writing
these verses because the column like
that you have to be writing it versus
someone you have to be assuming there's
someone saying that there is a huge deal
but nobody said that and then watching
stelter last night he tried to be like
i'm mr consistent he was like listen i'm
not gonna be like those other guys i'm
gonna actually say like it was wrong
okay because i'm but when you know trump
said that about chuck todd he said it
was a threat to our free press so saying
something is kind of wrong and then a
threat to the free press aren't exactly
consistent then he also said you know
we'd be milking it all day which again
we've been joking around both peter and
his dad work here and they're both like
yeah exactly and peter's mom took it
very well yeah
i mean she's the victim in all of this
by the way no
where is the journalist interviewing his
mom yeah because usually when someone's
referring to him well in my neighborhood
if you call me a son of a [ __ ] just go
time cause no one talks about my mama
yeah you know what i'm saying so let's
just take a moment of silence for her
yeah our very own but you've got
russians have insider information they
know what they're talking about if they
say it yeah you know that uh uh jimmy
kimmel called ducey last night a uh also
a dumb son of a bee and that was a
direct lift from what jesse waters said
he just stole water's joke yeah which is
so pathetic it also just sucks that
everyone who calls me names none of them
are famous no that'll happen one day one
day
because you're saying i have been yeah
you got to put the words major league
yeah yeah that's right that's right i'm
not really that good at name calling you
know that i should get better at it
no you're more of like a structured
paragraph insult exactly like you have
to you're all
yeah it's
it's not just it's a whole he tells you
why
that would stop it you know future
shut up yeah scathing email shut up both
of you
go to your rooms hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else